the MRI scanner was invented in 1977 and
its revolutionized medical Diagnostics
short for magnetic resonance imaging an
MRI offers an inside look at the human
body without surgery or x-rays when
investigating health problems it's a
great way to get the picture
using magnetic fields and radio wave
pulses an MRI can look right through you
to determine what's going on under your
skin
the magnet is incredibly powerful it's
up to 30 000 times stronger than the
Earth's magnetic field
[Music]
to make an MRI scanner they weld
aluminum casing around the magnet
creating a tunnel in the center for the
patient
the seams must be extremely tight
because the tube will also contain the
super cold liquid helium which will make
the magnet so incredibly powerful
once the welds are complete they cap the
magnet and transfer it to a test chamber
they pump helium gas into the tube and
activate a vacuum system that sucks out
the air in the chamber
a sensor confirms there are no leaks and
the welds are tight
they now construct a second aluminum
tube around the magnet this will act as
an insulating Shield
they wrap an aluminized mylar blanket
tightly around the magnet
aluminized mylar was first developed as
an insulating material for spacesuits in
this case it'll be used to deflect heat
to keep the magnet cold
they now insert the magnet into a steel
shell this is known as the vacuum vessel
because air will be pulled from the
space between it and the magnet creating
a vacuum which will serve as another
insulator
foreign
[Music]
they mask the MRI tunnel with plastic
and spray paint the exterior White
paint will protect the steel from rust
next they install a refrigeration unit
known as a cold head
the cold head will maintain the helium
around the mri's primary magnet at the
incredibly chilly temperature of minus
269 degrees Celsius this will keep the
helium in a liquid state
without the cold head significant
amounts would vaporize and be lost
they now pump the liquid helium into the
magnet
it's one of the coldest things on the
planet and the fill nozzles turn Frosty
stream cold the magnet loses all
electrical
[Music]
regenerating intense magnetic fields
with the MRI magnet complete they move
on to the gradient coil which will
control the orientation of the image
with electrical pulses
it starts with a fiberglass epoxy tube
cut to the correct length
a worker carves grooves in the tube and
fills those grooves with epoxy
[Music]
he then winds copper wire into the epoxy
field grooves and it adheres forming the
gradient coil
[Music]
the team slathers epoxy onto the entire
tube the epoxy seals the wire preventing
vibrations of the coil when it's in
operation
foreign
copper plates onto the epoxy and they
adhere
[Music]
they wrap the coil tightly with Teflon
cloth
[Music]
a worker pours epoxy resin onto the
fabric
he then winds tubing around the gradient
coil and it adheres to the epoxy coated
cloth these are cooling lines they'll
disperse heat generated by the gradient
coil
another worker now perhaps the next
fiberglass tube this one is for the
mri's radiofrequency coil
there's much more to come before this
MRI scanner is ready to provide an
inside look at the human body work on
the mri's radio frequency coil is
underway a technician attaches plastic
risers and pads to the fiberglass core
the risers and pads will hold the
circuitry Parts at a uniform level she
applies adhesive-backed strips of copper
from one band of risers to the other
these copper strips are the antenna
they'll send and receive signals from
the body and relay them to a computer to
produce the MRI image
[Music]
foreign
she presses the copper with a round Tim
tool for better adhesion to the Core
she then dabs epoxy glue into the Riser
compartments
[Music]
she inserts capacitors into the
Bluefield compartments these little
capacitors will store energy and change
the frequency of the coil to match the
magnets
[Music]
the technician solders the ends of the
capacitors to The Copper antenna as she
builds the circuitry
[Music]
she transfers numerous high voltage
inductor boards to the pads and screws
them in place
[Music]
next up are cable splitter units another
technician installs one near an inductor
board
[Music]
she routes some of the cables from the
splitter to several of the inductors
[Music]
and she solders the cables to the
inductors
[Music]
she places a plastic cable track on the
side of the radio frequency coil and
snakes the main power cable through it
[Music]
he solders the cable to the antenna
foreign
[Music]
stiffens the copper antenna with
composite boards to dampen vibrations
when the MRI is in operation
she applies epoxy around all the cables
the epoxy secures the cables to keep
them from moving around and making noise
the MRIs radio frequency coil is
complete and ready to be put to the test
the next worker caps the ends with metal
domes and bolts them tightly to it
[Music]
he pumps highly pressurized air into the
capped radio frequency coil
[Music]
she sprays soapy water over the exterior
of the coil and looks for air bubbles
bubbles in the Soapy residue would
indicate a leak that would disrupt
airflow in the MRI
with the radio frequency coil leak free
they now slide it into the gradient coil
which has gained an outer fiberglass
shell since we last saw it
[Music]
foreign
ER connects exterior tubing to the
network of cooling lines inside the
gradient coil
with those connections made they're
ready to assemble the coils to the
magnet the worker slides the assembly
off the cart and into the MRI magnet
he installs a bracket that centers the
coils maintaining a small gap between
them and the magnet
[Music]
he equips the MRI with microphones and
speakers to communicate with the patient
there's also a signaling system here for
the patient to activate in the event of
an emergency
[Music]
now for the ultimate test they energize
the magnet and sends standard test
objects into the MRI
they scan the objects and confirmed that
the picture is clear
they add a metal and plastic outer
casing this MRI scanner is now ready to
focus on diagnosis
the next picture it takes could be a
lifesaver
[Music]